vamos a repasar la situación que ha
estado emergiendo en grecia y luego
vamos a meternos un poquito en los
detalles de sus opciones como vimos en
el vídeo pasado grecia estaba gastando
estaba gastando mucho más de lo que
estaba recibiendo por ingresos de
impuestos que sus ingresos por impuestos
entonces eso causaba ciertos déficits
esos déficits se apilaron año tras año y
con esto la deuda nacional creció la
deuda creció para hacer las cosas
todavía peor crece intentó cubrir esto
por varios años con unos cuantos
fantasmas de contabilidad porque había
algunas reglas en el banco central
europeo- acerca de qué tanta deuda
puedes tener y entonces grecia hizo
algunos números turbios para poder
seguir pidiendo prestado de modo que
pudiera seguir financiando este gasto de
por acá pero luego en los últimos años
en los años recientes los fantasmas
fueron exorcizados y cuando se
exorcizaron pues fueron muy claros
número uno que había algo como que muy
turbio por ahí verdad pero más aún se
dieron cuenta que había una deuda mucho
más grande de lo que se pensaba le voy a
poner aquí más de lo que se pensaba
y la combinación de ambos verdad de este
este país ocultando todas sus
obligaciones con trucos de contabilidad
de esta falta de transparencia con el
mercado y el hecho de que esta deuda
fuera tan grande hizo que las personas
se volvieran muy desconfiadas del país
entonces la gente empezó a dudar de esto
dejar pongo por aquí la confianza
disminuye vale la confianza de los
inversionistas
los inversionistas básicamente son sus
prestamistas pero bueno ellos bajaron su
confianza y entonces esperaron una mayor
tasa de interés vale para poder hacerle
préstamos eso hizo que las cosas
empeorarán todavía más ahora a grecia no
sólo tenía que gastar vaya crucen sus
gastos corrientes sino que además ahora
para financiar todos esos gastos
corrientes se tuvo que recurrir a más
deuda y lo feo es que ahora esa deuda
aumentó de precio aumentó el interés
básicamente es como meterle más leña a
la hoguera y hacer que el problema se
haga mucho mucho peor bueno en el vídeo
pasado exploramos una opción hablamos de
la austeridad qué tal que simplemente
pues bueno podemos intentar aumentar el
ingreso
baja de gasto en el vídeo pasado nos
enfocamos más en el gasto pero la idea
era que tal que cortamos los gastos lo
más que podamos así para vivir al límite
de lo que podemos había varios problemas
de los cuales platicamos verdad lo
primero es que es impopular así
políticamente no le cae bien a la gente
que el gobierno no cumpla sus promesas
pero el segundo problema es que una vez
que estás en una recesión entonces esto
hace que la recesión empeore todavía más
entonces le pongo la recesión empeora
empeora y pues realmente sí o sea nunca
nunca es popular verdad pero en este
contexto esto es todavía más impopular
porque grecia ya ha pasado por más de
una ronda de austeridad por varias esto
no es un problema nuevo en realidad
grecia fue poco a poco acumulando deuda
y acumulando errores es como una bola de
nieve que se va haciendo cada vez más y
más grande y entonces conforme fue
pidiendo más ayuda a la unión europea la
unión europea le fue pidiendo más y más
condiciones de cortar el gasto pero
bueno qué pasó finalmente después de
tanta austeridad pues eso lo que hizo
fue alentar la economía eso lo que hizo
fue que la
sesión fuera peor y todavía peor verdad
porque si el gobierno deja de gastar
entonces pues ya sabes disminuye el
flujo de efectivo y eso hizo las cosas
muy malas verdad entonces otra opción es
la siguiente porque no simplemente
grecia deja de pagar lo pongo por aquí
incumplimiento de pago vale o sea que
sea simplemente dice bueno soy un país
perdón inversionistas pero la verdad no
les puedo pagar pero esto tiene un
problema aquí y ya está en la situación
en la cual gasta más de lo que genera y
todas sus deudas todas sus obligaciones
están en euros están de negro porque
pues no tiene su propia moneda entonces
qué pasa si caen en incumplimiento de
deuda pues obviamente número uno los
inversionistas van a estar súper
enojados y obviamente no le van a
prestar más dinero a grecia qué sucede
si nadie le presta dinero a grecia si
nadie le presta euros pues entonces
grecia ya no va a poder gastar euros
verdad y pues ya había prometido
muchísimo a sus a su población lo de los
de las pensiones y todo eso y como ya
cayó en el cumplimiento de pago ya no le
van a poder prestar y una vez más
en una situación fea y muy violenta
verdad hoy estamos en una austeridad
forzada una austeridad como muy
dramática que va a pasar prácticamente
se va a caer el gobierno entonces esto
de por aquí no es una buena opción vamos
a explorar una tercera opción y según yo
esta es la opción que pues es un poco
más llamativa vamos a pensar qué
sucedería si grecia fuera independiente
monetariamente vamos a ver qué sucede si
iglesia tiene su propia moneda recuerda
que todo lo que voy a hablar a partir de
ahorita es hipotético sea grecia solía
tener el dracma antes del euro pero
ahorita ya no porque ya está en el euro
vamos a pensar qué sucedería otra vez
hipotéticamente si si tuviera su propia
moneda va esto no es tan raro de pensar
porque históricamente grecia si ha
podido tomar prestado a tasas de interés
bajas por estar en la zona europea pero
vamos a pensar ahorita qué sucedería
vale si fuera independiente si tuviera
su propio banco central
entonces esto empieza a partir del vídeo
pasado entonces qué sucedería si tuviera
su propio banco central le voy a poner
aquí hipotético para hacer muy claro que
en que todo esto de acá es es una más
imaginándonos cosas vale porque hasta
ahorita todos los euros se imprimen por
el banco central europeo no por un país
pero hipotéticamente si tuviera un banco
central les voy a poner aquí banco
central griego
y que pueda imprimir no sé vamos a
ponerle el nuevo dracma entonces qué
sucedería con este banco central bueno
entonces el banco podría empezar a
imprimir drug más muchos muchos drug más
y esencialmente usar eso de ahí para
comprar bonos gubernamentales valores
gubernamentales entonces mi primer
dinero compra esos bonos y lo que está
haciendo es prácticamente prestarle
dinero al gobierno déjame le pongo por
acá y el gobierno puede gastarlo en sus
obligaciones porque ya tienen los
billetes del banco central esto se ve
muy turbio verdad esencialmente una
parte que está más o menos asociada con
el gobierno imprime dinero y se lo
presta el dinero para financiar sus
obligaciones pero aquí son algo raro
verdad o sea simplemente cuando el
primer moneda todo esto de acá que no
nos llevaría a que hubiera mucha
inflación inflación y pues la respuesta
es que si realmente si ya va a llevar
inflación pero eso va a ser la solución
deja te platico porque número uno la
inflación puede que no sea tan mal la
verdad mira ahorita
el país está en una recesión pues muy
fea entonces o sea tiene un colchoncito
de precios y además lo de acá arriba la
inflación no ha sido tan alta verdad no
es muy baja no es muy alta entonces va a
haber inflación pero creo que va a ser
controlable o sea no hay que preocuparse
por una situación de hiperinflación sin
embargo yo afirmo que al gobierno le
conviene tener una inflación
decentemente alta al músculo no quiera
una inflación de 1000 o de 100 pero yo
creo que una como de 20 o 10 si le
conviene y para justificar esto pues
piensa en la idea de que en esta a
grecia hipotética todas las obligaciones
ya no estarían en negro ya estarían en
dracmas entonces vamos a imaginar un
mundo voy a seguir diciendo hipotético
hipotético para que nos quede bien claro
les voy a poner unos números hipotéticos
y bueno tomemos está grecia hipotética o
cualquier país supongamos que tenemos un
producto interno bruto en ésta grecia
hipotética un pib d
me voy a poner así desde 100 de 100 si
en lo que sea su moneda baja vamos a
decirle dragma y vamos a suponer que sus
obligaciones sus obligaciones que
todavía tiene que pagar
obligaciones todo esto de acá está como
en términos anuales va son 10 mil
millones va a poner 100 mil millones
vale entonces bueno estando en la
situación de grecia porque sus
obligaciones están en euros pero en esta
situación hipotética supongamos que
además de estas dos cosas tiene una
cierta deuda que su deuda total su deuda
externa supongamos que es digamos 150
mil millones de su moneda entonces vamos
a ver qué sucede si tenemos inflación
qué sucede después de la inflación bueno
si tenemos la inflación del 100 por
ciento por decir algo de entre entre
algunos años y tú producto interno bruto
no cambia que sería muy difícil pero
bueno es nada más un experimento mental
para ir entendiendo estas cosas pero
bueno si seguimos produciendo lo mismo
entonces el valor nominal por la
inflación ahora sería de 200 miles de
millones y es la misma buena es la misma
cantidad de bienes y servicios pero
ahora todo va a costar el doble ok
entonces si no ajusta sal inflación de
todas formas sería 100 millones pero
las cosas buenas y bueno es raro usar la
inflación en un buen buen contexto pero
la parte padre es que estas obligaciones
también serían de 10 mil millones de
todas formas vamos a decir sabes que te
voy a pagar 10 mil millones aunque estás
ese dinero ya no te ayude a comprar
tanto y eso es políticamente mucho más
correcto que decirle a las personas que
van a cortar su pensión a la mitad este
sería un suicidio político pero ahorita
con inflación nominalmente parece que
estás pagando lo mismo solo que puedes
comprar menos es mucho más viable lo
mismo pasa con la deuda sus obligaciones
de deuda incluso después de la inflación
van a seguir siendo de 150 mil millones
pero ahora como un porcentaje del
producto interno bruto ha llevado a la
mitad de este numerito has bajado en 50%
estás obligación entonces esto de aquí
es una solución viable en esta situación
hipotética probablemente sea la mejor
solución para el gobierno esencialmente
inflar las deudas para eliminarlas si lo
voy a poner así inflar para eliminarlas
bueno voy a dejarle hasta aquí para que
pienses un poquito en lo que hemos
platicado y después vamos a ver cómo
podríamos adaptar ésta
estrategia para resolver el problema de
grecia pero más importante aún vamos a
platicar porque todo el mundo está
preocupado por grecia porque la unión
europea dice no no no sabes que es que
creo que si tenemos que hacer un rescate
financiero porque si no esto va estar
super feo y las cosas se van a poner muy
negras bueno el próximo vídeo vamos a
hablar justo cuáles son las
repercusiones de que se haga esto en el
mercado global pero bueno por el momento
le dejo hasta aquí